afternoon
results from the nevada primary are
providing now a clearer picture of what
november and the election will look like
mail-in ballots though are accepted
through friday so some of those aren't
the very final vote totals quite yet but
two men very familiar with each other
they're going to go head-to-head for the
governor's seat governor steve sisilak
easily won the democratic nomination
over former clark county commissioner
tom collins and metro sheriff joe
lombardo has won the gop nomination with
38 percent of the vote overtaking his
competition reno attorney joey gilbert
and former senator dean heller with
sheriff lombardo running for governor
clark county is in need of a new sheriff
three police veterans were vying for the
top cop spot former undersheriff kevin
mcmahon won outright by a landslide with
more than half the vote 60 percent in
fact he served with metro for decades
and for the senate former attorney
general adam blacksad will be facing off
with democratic incumbent catherine
cortes masto he took more than half of
the vote despite a pretty strong
challenge for newcomer army veteran sam
brown
and several spots open for the clark
county school board of trustees these
are nonpartisan races which means that
if no one gets the 50 percent the top
two vote getters will face each other on
the ballot in november and it is a tight
race let's start with district d
stephen conger now has a slim lead over
irene cepeda who's the incumbent as for
district f irene bustamante a former
nevada assembly woman is ahead of
incumbent danielle four 21 to 18 percent
they'll likely be facing each other in
november as well and finally for
district g
linda cavazos
the only one of the incumbents in the
lead in her race and that'll also go to
a runoff against greg wieman
let's check the weather